this week we've got butterfly effect
cold case arrests and Denny's attacks
butter flavor yep
now those are more very like what's a
butterfly effect isn't that a movie
movie good time like the thing of a
butterfly 20 psychologists and then they
show you all these people pornos - it's
pictures of pornos but they don't like a
butterfly no butterfly effect is that
theory that if you go back in time to
dinosaur age and you kill a butterfly it
will have like a dump everything would
be different at this point that's kind
of crazy to think about cuz I kind of
believe in it yeah I think so huh yeah
that Ashton Kutcher movie so it was a
dinosaur yep you saw it huh yeah yeah so
there was this drama students at the
University of Hartford we all drama
students at this point in this kind of
setting yeah I mean I was never a drama
drama I notice I'm taking the [ __ ] out
of here
are we all ciamis dudes at this point
[Laughter]
thank you
yes so then they're saying that they
were acting out this scene from the
movie butterfly effect and that's when
he apparently just got so sucked into
his role that he just started stabbing
people what did this for Oscar dude
[Laughter]
absolutely
so there were two victims a 19 year old
and a 20 year old when did he when did
he get the real knife though okay so
yeah it was part of some theme that was
part of the scene to stop people I don't
remember that I don't know what scene
they're talking about the only one I can
think of was when he got something he
stabbed his own hand yeah
hope I didn't do that right she stopped
other people yeah so you said that so
there was a 19 year old in a 21 year old
he's 20 and so what he did is he started
stabbing the 19 year old students in his
chest and back Oh
multiple times yes
that's crazy yeah oh no he started
stabbing the 21 year old first and the
same thing like on his chest and
everything and that's when the 19 year
old started like pleading with him to
stop and then that's when he started
having the night how does no one like
tackle him that's like my first things
to like go on top of them that's because
you're [ __ ] East LA [ __ ] most people
don't see that [ __ ] on a regular basis
delay on Pico okay people saying she
minutes we're pretty similar yeah yeah
yeah and then so a witness said that
potato montana that they saw a six to
seven inch kitchen knife a
nineteen-year-old 1001 is in critical
condition and the other ones stable oh
my god that's crazy dude yep so the 21
year old student was stabbed four times
in the back once in the chest and the 19
year old
these were his scene partners or after
the stage whatever rehearsal was over he
may but actually I was in a dorm that
happen like they were there were anyone
in class or anything
I already picture what this guy dress is
like I feel like because I had these
people in my high school Doc Martens in
the black trench so if you look like
that
I have Doc Martens but not a med trench
coat
now dress in black so they weren't drama
students or they were drawn yeah they
were right go ahead that's what the 20
year old his name is Jake that's what he
claims like what happened was like they
were acting out this thing and then he
just got so lost in the role he just
started stabbing people so after he
stabbed these two people he ran into the
woods and the police ended up finding
him in the wooded area but they found
him with the whole bunch of scratches on
his face cuz of like running through the
woods and [ __ ] naked he was naked
oh my bad I didn't saw a picture naked
just [ __ ] move it some people got so
what Jake looks like what he's not 20
years old whiny Jake that's not a 20
year old dude he looks solid 40 years
old dude look at the wisdom in his eyes
dude
I know he has some crazy things that's
so this was a college drama club this is
it he's 21
yeah what kind of [ __ ] did 20 year old
looks like that get the [ __ ] out of
you're not twenty dude Medina looks
older yeah but when did deme shave this
[ __ ] like a little child
that's true yes sir maybe if he shapes
he'll look like a baby I don't know look
at those eyes though she look crazy I
don't know why like I feel like actors
and drama club people are always a
little bit ticked off you know what I
mean like you know how athletes you have
to be some sort of like a kind of level
of like [ __ ] up to like go and push
your body all the way like I feel like
actors and like drama club kids were
always like that too like they were
always different in high school you know
you always saw them and they were like
doing their thing in the corner like
acting when no one was asking them to
you know nobody's asking you to hang go
[ __ ] you do you though you know what I
mean but it just was always out there
they were always super out there yeah
yeah definitely parts of their brain
that they're firing more than the
average person
yeah like to not be ashamed in front of
an audience and like act the scene so
maybe he could go with that are they
believing him um I don't know they are
but he obviously got a rest especially
cuz oh he did get arrested there's no
scene like that in the movie that's
crazy Dan so wait what's critical
condition mean like they might not die
yeah yeah it's critical you know when
I've seen to it like if number one it's
like he's like yo I'm gonna use an
actual night up like no you [ __ ]
imagine that [ __ ] knife dude do some
space work [ __ ] like the [ __ ] a real
knife to the shit's [ __ ] my mission
yes he's been charged with two counts of
attempted murder and two counts of
first-degree assault
so they're not believing him that's good
well even if they believe him I still
know he did it yes I guess if you would
have done it like you know like in the
year the show play you know I mean like
where there was people actually watching
that he would have gone down in history
but now he just like if they were just
practicing what's the point you actually
killed your co-stars didn't go out with
a bang right I would have gone out with
the bang if it was me true
that's happened too long we will have
gotten injured
I remember hearing something about a
knife being switched out and someone
like actually stabbing so maybe that was
a movie I watched oh no that's the other
one I was gonna say Brent
Brendan Lee with the gun and he actually
got shot when we were filming a real gun
yeah that was pretty crazy - you move on
to the next story there was this man who
was cut finally after 20 years for a
killing back in 1998 and this was
because he was applying for a job as a
certified nurse assistant and during
that application he needed to submit his
fingerprints for the app for like the
background check and that's when his
fingerprints popped up as a suspect in
this cold case of his murder on the 68
year-old woman named Sandra that stuff
actually works huh yeah so thank
goodness he was caught and they're
saying that when they arrested him he
just had no emotion wait how did he kill
her he stabbed her and blood bludgeoned
her to death like she just broke into
her house like he knew her it wasn't a
house it was so she was working at this
consignment store and he went to go get
stuff and the cops are assuming that he
was trying to rob the place and that's
death and it was her store or this you
just worked there she just worked there
she was actually that week I think she
got killed like on a Monday or Tuesday
and that Friday she was gonna be like
retiring like she was a mess [ __ ] up
yeah she was also gonna renew her vows
with her husband but then she if it's
not my store I don't fight it at all
meaning you know they're like give me a
[ __ ] note they tell you to like here
you go even if it is my store I don't I
just don't think it's worth it
like your life is more important than
anything you have going on so take
everything [ __ ] it take my butthole if
you want it's like it's not [ __ ] that
bro it's like my store somebody comes up
and they're like give me all the [ __ ]
money in the register right now I
stopped yelling bro
we're gonna give it to you in [ __ ]
low your voice bro what's wrong with you
man hey yo each one is sequential one so
what's up
that's how I did too damn fast City of
God yeah oh yeah remember they're like
robbing people - like what it's just
your bosses money why do you care
yeah yeah you know it is like that I
wouldn't in same thing I wouldn't yeah
that's kind of scary dude Justin they'll
put him on the front of barbel
everything please
great disease homie ma'am I just figure
this [ __ ] out
take it best bite dust that when you
work Black Friday they tell you because
people literally come in and take TVs
like they'll put them in the car and
just walk out with them and they say if
you see anyone stealing I let them go
like no one is worth Lucy over anything
so I mean you know no you know for Best
Buy on Black Friday yes let's go on
Black Friday they will not chase you for
sure stealing is too much work it's too
much stress
yeah lotta stress man too much stress
dude so this is Todd oh my god
51 years old what does he look like that
why what does he look like - he's a
murderer
I don't know you could at least afford a
proper barber or something if you're
stealing from people she looks so good
1998 is one she died this was David's
wardrobe yo real talk
that is no way to go man that was fast
man wait is this in America yeah yeah
I'm asking you beyond the murderer dude
how you murder somebody in flip-flops
this was in Florida well that's why Stu
explains the haircut you got oh yeah and
then to kill someone stabbing that my
phone would be really hard like a gun
shot is easier but to stab them to have
to do a lot like tires oh yeah do it oh
you could smell them you can feel
they're warm and like poke I feel like I
could stab someone if I really hated him
do you really hate anyone that much
right now
no but I'm he did if I'm heated and like
let's say the person in the room with me
if I had a gun or a knife
I'll pie take the knife I'm gonna be way
more fun but what would a 68 year old
woman do - oh yeah no not - girl I like
someone that [ __ ] with me
yeah like honestly you could stab her
once and show fall and take the money
you could just push her over and she's
already on the floor Oh 68 no that's
what are you ways to beat up a 16 year
old you get Ripper like you know when
you're used to walking you to hit your
friend's foot yeah they trip I just
[ __ ] tire and be like lucky little
lady just chill
have you seen old people fall it takes
like three minutes you can just like
knocked her over and as she's falling
for three minutes gonna take the money
on a walk and then gone away yeah and
there everyone lives happily ever after
maybe he killed her so she wouldn't
recognize him and he wouldn't get caught
I'm [ __ ] aw he got caught in they
still got to live 20 years like I know
that's not fair you guys about to be
someone certified nursing assistant oh
that's good oh he would have killed a
lot more people you think so or you
think it was like a crime of passion
just cuz he was like in a rush or do you
think he was like a serial killer I
think he just kills with no remorse cut
no dude don't trust that [ __ ] dude bad
haircut all right
for last story there was this Denny's
customer that was viciously attacked
after defending employees
I haven't been adenosine a long time I
[ __ ] love Denny's dude the midnight
slam burger homie why I hate Denny's
because no matter which Denny's I go to
the service sucks what you haven't been
the one in every single one every single
one my order takes like a freaking hour
and a half to get to my table I'm like
real up you Denny do you sit on the
farthest table though no do you always
go on a Sunday morning no you got on a
Tuesday at 12:00 yeah duh
every time cuz you know that one endow
me with any good it would take me full
of [ __ ] ever to get my food and I
really knock you back it's got really
hungry no and then I went to one here
like around here and then I went to this
other one in Hollywood and I went to
this other one Pasadena doll slaw
[ __ ] Colorado that one's the [ __ ] I
will defend that [ __ ] for the rest of my
life and I like the food it's just I
take Brad pretty much like a want to do
a brand deal with you know I'll be like
the lumberjack slab day the midnight
slam burger the moons over my hammy the
super boot to your house like [ __ ] yeah
I love then I love the food the food is
the one in k-town dude that was the
midnight eats bro that [ __ ]
Oh mom you know even the one in Vegas
284 [ __ ] yet go to Denny's in Vegas I
don't care what it's right next night oh
yeah you know what it was like next to
Harris okay you need to change your
friends I would never been there this
every the world is at your fingertips
and you're going to Danny's this was
good for me what I'm glad you change
your friend wait [ __ ] fries yeah the
$4 prime rib yeah biggis is cheese who
dollars taking eggs okay but my mind I
could only think of like I can't my mind
was [ __ ] cheap I couldn't afford it
what about the giant billboard on the
side of the freeway were staking it for
$2 anyway so this happened in Fremont
California and this man was left with
broken bones and three missing teeth
where would act would happen any studies
yeah the Denny's so apparently what
happened here there was this door -
driver that was berating employees at
Denny's because his order was not ready
big surprised anything forever
and so he was started yelling at the
employees and then that's when this
customer named Frederick he stepped in
and said like hey you need to calm down
oh you want to be a hero I will not be a
hero is a dead [ __ ]
I mean exactly like people yelling is
just a mob yawns yeah and so then that's
when the driver pushed him and then he
punched him in the face and ran away but
that one punch like he suffered a lot of
injury oh my strongest got pretty
fractured nose and play palette palette
daddy push him hard dazzl strong and he
received ten stitches in his lip damn
what a good pun punch weight training in
I know that's right there's from one
punch oh maybe he plays that arcade game
a lot the one that you just punch the
bag and like it it's crazy
is he flipping off the camera I think
he's just holding his bag of oh okay I
thought I thought he was gonna be funny
like hey he's the guy that threw the
punch no he's he's the one that was like
hey man calm down chill damn who's the
guy that threw the punch that got
300-pound I don't know
for real though dude or at least they
don't name him but they did say that
they had a lot of door - orders and yeah
door Josh said that they did deactivate
that dashers from their account or
platform whatever what did I name him in
the article cetera that's a crazy thing
was like uber like door - and all these
services like anyone can literally work
for them and like I remember I saw this
one thing on Twitter that was like this
guy was like hey man do you mind some
extra sauce on my order and the I was
like it's 25 cents extra he's like I'll
give them to you when you got here he
was like you're trying to fight like it
just escalated away shut up like 500
quarters and sauce yeah literally like
it was like what you could've had it in
your order and I was like dude can you
just add it for me
people are crazy out there you know
what's interesting I think like no
matter how old I get just because it's
still a very uncomfortable thing for
somebody I don't know to come to my door
I Muriel told told me that I speak very
aggressively so like it wasn't even our
order but somebody came to our to our
apartment thinking that it was they
delivered basically Chinese food to the
wrong place let the Panda in next to us
and then I open the door I don't know
who the [ __ ] this guy is as I deliver it
outside it's not my [ __ ] like the first
thing I said because I don't know this
guy you know especially like because I'm
in an apartment now it's just direct
access to everything that I have so it's
like I don't know if I feel a lot more
wrong
so I'm like I don't know this guy and
I'm like this was my [ __ ] robbed me
that's the first thing I think about but
he's just like doing his job but I guess
Muriel told me that I speak aggressively
look what did the guy say when he said
that uh he goes oh I must have got the
wrong water I was like yeah it's cool
cuz I don't know the guy it makes me
feel like he's trying to do some [ __ ]
yeah well the [ __ ] are you at my door
like 10 p.m. at night actually answered
the door
butt-naked and I buy my bottom lip make
someone come to run never take the food
in videos not your assistant yeah I know
I saw recently like Gio was pointing out
the face now seal the bags sticker I
love that cuz everytime I only keep taco
no huh no it's a new thing like they're
eating my [ __ ] I know that I would just
think like imagine if someone wants
people are disgusting dude and then they
could just be like I don't want to think
about it you know and I mean like oh oh
like that oh we did this story where
this dude dipped his nuts and oh yeah
was I here I don't know I watched it but
yeah yeah I remember yeah you know that
Hong Kong milk do you order for me the
other day that person they deliver the
drinks upside down I was sitting on the
table upside down why and it wasn't even
like the bulbasaur steel style it sure
yeah it was all over the bag I'm like
what the football would they leave
deliver like that so weird anahat cup
holders so it was two drinks with the
cup holder and the couple's unserious
yeah that person literally didn't know
what they were doing there just I I
think this is right what ya do people
are gross
[Music]
[Music]